[Music]
hello all welcome and thank you for
joining us for this webinar
my name is lindsay nelson i am the life
science technology platform leader for
oncology reagents at perkin elmer
today's webinar is titled innovative
approaches to investigating k-ras
therapeutics with biochemical and cell
based assays
i am very pleased to introduce our
presenter elite dupuis an r d project
manager and team leader focused on
developing homogeneous assays including
tips specifically for k-ras research
take it away elderly
thank you lindsay and hello everyone
thank you for joining us today for this
presentation on new kiras research
solutions
today we are going to look at some
innovative biochemical and cell-based
assays to study kira's and source one
binders
as well as some research applications
they open and the kind of results they
achieve
before we dive in
let me explain a couple of things about
the presentation
first
this will be followed by a q a session
so please
all your questions until then
second this presentation will code data
from different sources including notes
that have been published by perkinelmer
all of these will be shown at the end of
this presentation
first up let's have an introduction to
race proteins what they are what they do
and why they are of interest to us
more than
150 human race proteins have been
identified and classified in six
families
these proteins are important playing the
role of signal transducers for pathways
that regulate numerous intracellular
functions including cell growth
proliferation differentiation and
survival
breast protein mutations have been found
to drive more than 30 percent of all
human cancers across a wide range of
cancer types
the keras iso form accounts for 85
percent of all rash mutations
thus intense research initiatives are
underway globally to develop effective
therapeutic approaches
for keras driven cancers
the human genome contains two copies of
the keras gene
here has two gene
has six exons and alternating splicing
of exon 4 produces two
mrna forms which in turn gives rise to
two protein isoforms which are qs4a and
qs4b
the qrs4b variant predominates in human
cells and is commonly known as kiras
at perkinermer we are working with this
variant
eurasian mutations occur most frequently
at codons 12 13 and 61
and are present in many types of human
tumors including pancreatic colon and
lung canxinomas
the diversity of keras mutations that
cause human cancers and a persistent
difficulty in identifying new mutations
are the drivers for multiple types of
keras therapies being developed and that
are already in use
in terms of background moving on to
kira's and sensos1 as key interacting
protein partners implicated in many
cancers
keras are g proteins that contain four
domains including a conserved gdp gtp
binding domain and two switch regions
that determine how they react to their
substrate and environment
conformational changes in the switch
regions allow keras proteins to have
many potential configurations and
interaction with various partners such
as
guanine nucleotide exchange factors the
gef
promoting formation
of the kira's gtp bond active form the
onstate
gtp has activating proteins the gap
promoting formation of the inner
inactive gdp bound form the octate and
effectors promoting activation of
downstream cascades of signaling
pathways
in the normal phys physiological context
keras is mainly in the inactive gdp
bound state
the conversion of keras from its
inactive from
to the active state is mediated by gaf
the gif of interest is sus1 which is a
multi-domain protein containing both
n-terminal and c-terminal regions joined
by a helical
linker which acts as a hinge allowing
source one to adopt both an active
membrane-bound conformation and an
auto-inhibited cytosolic conformation
the interaction between gdp kiras and
the catalytic site of source 1
leads to gdp release
an allosteric binding site also exists
functions as a positive feedback loop
and binds gtp qras more strongly than
gdp kiras promoting activation of source
1
catalytic activity upon kira's binding
there are two approaches to targeting
kiras
selective keras therapies and pancreas
therapies
selective kiras approaches target one
oncogenic mutant whereas pancreas
therapies target multiple keras
mutations
and the direct inhibition of source one
belongs to this class of therapies
now moving on to
map
chinese eye readouts in kira's oncogenic
cellular contexts
activated keras activate effector
proteins that promote downstream cascade
of signaling pathways and promote cell
cycle progression
through say replication
growth differentiation and chemotaxis
current mutations that cause oncogenic
activity and different characteristics
in different cancer types result in
kira's protein stuck in the gtp-bound
form
when a keras protein is stuck in the
on-state position due to the mutation
downstream effector pathways
also remain active and tumor
proliferation remains high
investigations for specific inhibitions
of kira's downstream pathways are of
interest in cancer research
today we will discussing new solutions
upon traditional approaches focused on
qras and source one as partners in
biochemical and cell-based contexts for
kira's therapeutics research
first verkinermer has developed a
portfolio of biochemical assays to
characterize keras and sauce one binders
as inhibitors for their interaction
armor facilitates the screening of
kira's swan inhibitors by providing
commercially available no wash and ready
to use homogeneous kira sauce one
binding kits for kira suswan analyzes
available in both alphaliza and htrf
technologies these kits come with
detection regions sa buffers tagged
recombinant proteins and optimized
technique and optimized technical
procedure to perform the assays with no
optimization necessary and robust
validations with compound of reference
to bind keras wild type qrs g12c as
mutant and sus1
the assay principle goes as follow
compounds then recombinant and tagged
kira's gtp and sus1 proteins are
dispensed in miniaturized plates
finally hdrf and alphalyser detection
regions based on anti-tax strategies are
introduced prior to the incubation for
two hours
in terms of what dsas provide they are
biochemical assays
designed to identify specific inhibitors
targeting kira's g12c source one from
kira's y-type source one complexes
we have good demonstration of that
specificity on the slide
in the corresponding experiments a panel
of reference compounds have been tested
and the pharmacological ranking obtained
was well correlated with the specificity
described in the literature
that are not shown here but the
specificity was both demonstrated with
htrf and alphalyzer kid versions
also the results demonstrated the
ability of the kids to identify
inhibitors which can be source one
binders illustrated here with the bay
compound or keras binders illustrated
with all the user compounds shown here
as shown on the slide the same
experiments were also performed with the
gdp
as competitor nucleotide of the gtp
in order to illustrate the applicability
of the kira's source 1 binding kits to
also identify some compounds that are
actually gtp competitors as positive
it's by disturbing the binding of gtp on
kiras which is required for the
detection of the interaction with sus1
in this biochemical context
in order to identify the gtp competitors
among the positive hits additional
investigations can be performed with the
perky mirrors
hdrf and alphalyzer keras g12c and wild
type gtp binding kits
berkelmer facilitates the screening of
kira's gtp competitor by again providing
commercial commercially available no
wash and ready-to-use homogeneous kira's
binding kits for kira kira's g12c and
y-type analysis
available in both alphaliza and htrf
technologies like the cura source 1 kits
these kits comes with
detection regions ac buffers recombinant
proteins which are also tagged
and optimized
sa protocol to perform the assays with
no optimization necessary
and robust validations with nucleotides
of reference to complete the gtp on
kira's wild type and qrs g12
the the sa principle gaza's flow
compounds then tagged recombinant kiras
proteins are dispensed in miniaturized
plates
finally surf or alphalizer detection
regions based on anti-tax strategy and
fluorescent or biotin gtp
derivative are introduced prior to the
incubation for one or two hours
in terms of what the assays provide
there are biochemical assays designed to
identify specific compounds competing
the gtp bound in kira's g12c or
y-type we have a good demonstration of
that
competition on the slide in the
corresponding experiments a panel of
reference nucleotides and reference
kirasu swan binders have been
tested the competition profiles obtained
with all buenos guanosine nucleotides
and the absence of full inhibition
detected with all kira sus1 binders were
consistent with the data from the
literature
and the binding sites described for
kiras and suswan binders
data are not shown here but the
competition was both demonstrated with
htrf and alphalizer kit versions
also the kits enable the fine-tuned
characterizations of kira's gtp
allosteric compounds
for their binding close to the gtp
binding pocket on kiras
finally the qrs gtp binding kits enable
the discrimination of gtp competitors or
gtp allosteric modulators among a panel
of screen compounds from a chemical
library additionally to the key resource
one binding kits
now let's take a look at the summary of
what kind of studies all these assays
are aimed at
first the cura sus1 binding kits enable
the identification of positive aids as
competitors of gtp
and binders of key russell or sus1 for
inhibition
of kira susuan complexes implicating
kira's gtp bound
confirmation they enabled the
discrimination of specific inhibitors of
kira's d12 c source one complexes
from the kira's y-type source one ones
finally
they enabled the pharmacological
characterizations of compounds for their
potency efficacy and ranking
second the qrs gtp binding kits enable
the discrimination of gdp gtp
competitors and allosteric modulators
among the positive hits detected with
the kira sus1 binding kits
third the kiras portfolio provides
additional tools to further characterize
kira's sus1 compound's properties and
elucidate the mechanism of interactions
between keras source 1 and the gtp in
the biochemical context
all together
the perkiner mirrors curacas binding
kits provide new biochemical solutions
to screen pharmacological compounds and
estimate the potential of positive heat
to become a therapeutic tool for
cell-based investigations
burkinderma also provides a
comprehensive portfolio of htrf and
alpha larger
surefire ultra phospho-total cell-based
assays that help characterization of
kerose1 inhibitors on downstream kira
signaling
these cellular signaling assays enable
discrimination between the cellular
action of the heat compounds and
evaluation of their efficacy and potency
in modulating the downstream keras
pathways
these kits represent efficient tools for
the estimation of a tear-up of a
therapeutic profile for keras targeting
compounds in various cancer cell lines
the rc principle goes as flow
the assays were designed using using a
classic immunoassay sandwich format
based on the detection with antiphospho
and anti-total antibodies specific to
the protein as read out to be monitored
perform the assays
cells are dispensed in microplates
stimulated
then lies prior to detection
term of what these assay provide they
are cell-based assays designed to
evaluate in the cellular context the
compounds characterized in kerasuswan
biochemical assays and discriminate the
specific kikiras g12c inhibitors from
the whitehall ones
we have good demonstration of that
specificity on the slide in the cellular
context
in the corresponding experiment two
keras reference inhibitors were tested
on the hg-29 cells as colorectal cancer
cells in which only kira's wild type is
androgenously expressed
as expected result demonstrated the
inhibition of phosphorus and phosphomac
mediated by the bi inhibitor which is
described in the literature turbine
kira's wide type instead of no
inhibition was detected through amg
stimulation described in the literature
to be specific to keras t12c
that are not shown here but this
specificity was both demonstrated with
hgrf and alphalyser surface tracking
versions
results confirm the specificity of
pharmacological compounds previously
characterized with kira's source one
biochemical assays
the perkinelmers
phospho-total sales-based assays
portfolio also provide solutions for
fine-tuned characterizations
of source 1 binders in a kira's
downstream signaling cellular context
here we have a good demonstration
of the kind of results provided
in the corresponding experiments the
source one binder bay
was tested on two different cancer
cellular models
first the kl1 cells has lung cancer
cells in which only keras g12c is
androgenously expressed and second
the
the key562 cells has leukemia cells in
which only the kira's wild type version
is androgenously expressed
results demonstrated that
there is no effect on total hurt and
that there is an inhibition of
phosphorus in both cellular models
but interestingly the potency and
efficacy of the source one binder to
inhibit phosphorus as kira's downstream
signaling readouts were different
depending on the cellular model tested
the same conclusions can be made from
results obtained both with hdrf and
alphalizer surefire utracket versions
the conclusion of that study
is that by combining all perky normal
solutions including hdrf and alphaliza
keras biochemical assays and the hdrf
and alphalizar surefire ultra
phospho-total
cell-based assays fine-tuned
characterization of kira's source 1 and
gtp binders can be performed to
correctly identify compounds as
inhibitors for new therapeutic
strategies in oncology
to conclude this presentation i wanted
to take a look at the current perky
numerous catalogue for kira's
investigations
the listed shrf and alphalyzer curious
biochemical kit versions are available
and can be found online
regarding the cell-based signaling
essays
some of the relevant kits are listed
here but many others are also available
and can be found online too
finally before closing this presentation
i wanted to align the library of content
that perkin delmar has created for
curious researchers and scientists
including two application notes with
results and technical info about kira's
assays a white paper for more
educational purpose
and a guide with the key guidelines to
running cell signaling experiments
that's all for this presentation
thank you for your attention and we will
now start taking questions
okay thank you so much elite for that
presentation at this point we will take
any
any questions that you may have um as a
reminder on the right hand side of your
screen there's a little chat box to
enter any any questions you may have and
we will
answer as many as as we can as time
allowed
so it looks like uh we have a few
questions here in the queue
already the first question is are these
types of assays amenable to
miniaturization
uh yeah so this assay were optimized in
384 plates and we didn't test any other
acid formats
but
with these types of assays and
especially for the biochemical assays
uh with alphalizer and htrf technology
it's
totally possible to perform these assays
in a miniaturized format
to the 1536 well plates
so yes
these assays can be miniaturized by
optimizing volumes
of regents which are dispensed in the
plate
okay thank you elite uh second question
is
why did you choose fossil erc as a
readout in the cell cancer model
good question so we chose phosphorus as
a downstream without in keras signaling
for several reasons
and first because eric is a member of
the two main signaling pathways related
to curas
so it's a really irrelevant readout to
characterize kira's inhibitors in cells
and also because iraq is one of the more
described readout for active kira
signaling and it can be found in the
literature several papers mentioning
turas inhibitors which were tested in
different cancer cells
so
we could we could find any values
regarding specificity potency
uh on various type of cells
and
and finally because phosphorus is
implicated in numerous cancer cell
cellular processes including for example
migration apoptosis growth
differentiation and so on
so it's a really a relevant readout
great another question how could you
account for self-toxicity of the
compounds for your cell-based assays
what would your recommendation be
i'm sorry lindsay i i didn't hear the
the question
oh sure
so the question is about how could you
account for cell toxicity of the
compounds
for your cell-based assays
what would your recommendation be
in terms of looking at
maybe some
toxicity of compounds when running
cell-based gases
uh in fact you you cannot
you cannot monitor cell toxicity
uh by using only uh only these assays
but
it's really it's really useful to
compare the force for earth for example
and the total arc and
if you don't um detect any decrease of
signal um
it
it because that there is
um
no acetotoxicity
uh effect but
additionally to this kind of uh assay
you you can also
perform other
other
assays and for example our
atp lite assay
great thanks eldie the next question we
have is is it correct that the screening
with the k-rack soft one binding kit
will also identify gtp inhibitors
yes it is
and
because for these curas and sauce one
biochemical kits
the interaction between
both proteins is driven by the
concentration
of gtp
which is mandatory
to detect this interaction meaning that
if a compound competes with the gtp
the interaction between kiras and source
one will be altered so alphaliza and
htrf signals will decrease with these
kits
in the same way as for qras or source
one binders which inhibit the
interaction
thank you elite um let me just check the
queue list
um
another question is do you have athletes
optimized for other rasp isoforms such
as enraft or ahrefs and any of their
respective mutations
not for the moment but i guess it would
be very interesting to develop this kind
of assays
so maybe
we will have
these diskettes in the future
great thank you
[Music]
uh so someone asks that in your slide 13
led foster work and phosphomex signal
does not reach the bottom of the plot
can you maybe explain the reason for
this
is this normal or
could this be improved
in fact we observed that for some
compounds
the efficacy uh to inhibit the
the phosphorylation of erc
is totally different depending on the
cells
so for the
the compound which is presented on on
this slide so it's a bi
um
we observed that it's only a partial um
inhibition of phosphorylation
so that's why
it's not possible to to reach
the the plateau
to the negative
perfect thank you so much audi uh for
appearances
at the end of the time allotted for
questions so thanks to everybody who
submitted questions um and thanks so
much to everybody for attending and
again for led
for presenting details of her research
today so thanks again and have a great
day everybody bye-bye
you